in terms of the weekend itself uh bryson
deschambeau taking the us open
and then we saw what happened in week
two of the nfl and to discuss
all of that is our compadre and my uh
longtime friend from espn back in the
day now nbc sports
mike tarico how are you mike hi mr rich
how are we doing bud i'm well so did you
did you
wing it up from wing foot or hightail it
to um
connecticut for sunday night is that
what your sunday was all about
mike i did i did i i guess i guess that
would be a
never before done and never to be done
again you would think because the nfl
season of the u.s open aren't usually
right
in the same week so i uh yeah i was
hosting
and uh in the booth for thursday friday
than hosting
on nbc on saturday and sunday uh so
we got on the air at noon so did that
for four hours then right after the
leaders
uh went through the par three tenths i
hopped in a car
but 35 minutes up to the studio uh it
was pretty cool we had that
set up where we watched all nine games
and it was 10 yesterday in the early
window
in our screening room in connecticut at
our studio when we're doing football
night with tony dungy and
chris sims and rodney harrison and our
whole production group we actually
got a feed of that into my booth at
the golf so we had the us open on we
were hosting and i was watching
the nine of the one o'clock games it was
uh it was a overload afternoon but it
was great and then
went up there did the football night
show and then did uh halftime
with tony so it was a fun it was a fun
exhausting but uh
one of those once-in-a-lifetime days
yeah that's cool get the host
give out the major and sunday night
football
pre-game at halftime all in about eight
hours that's amazing and i guess to
put it all together greg zurline's
onside kick read like one of those putts
where you you know you just have to hit
it ten feet
let the break take it the rest of the
way it sort of looked like exactly like
that
collinsworth yeah cauldron said that
chris collins are they i have to specify
which one now yeah
said that during the game that it was it
was like a weak footprint it just kept
turning and turning it turned it was a
pretty neat deal it was just so strange
it's funny because we were talking about
how
the onsite kicks rarely get recovered
anymore and the
reigning king of the onside kicks right
now young boy co
was on the opposite sideline because he
got two
in one game that we did last year on
thanksgiving with atlanta
and so we're joking in our screening
room last week like well they got young
wake up they'll recover an onside kick
and they did
but he's the king of that and then
dallas pulls that one off
uh with great creativity and goes on to
win the game which is
amazing stuff i know and then next up is
seattle and then
uh but before we do continue on with
football a little bit here i do
let's let's start with the the first
part of your sunday it's been a long
time since
somebody won a major and we start
wondering what it means for this
the sport entirely i mean like tiger
might be the last one
um that we're wondering like what does
it mean the way that
he plays for everything and everyone
else is
is that too much to say about what
bryson deshambo did
this weekend or accurate mike no no it
it no
it shakes the foundation of it to have
uh self-examination now
let's be candid cameron champ hits it a
long way
matthew wolf hits it a long way still
the best guys in the world like john
rahm and dustin johnson and justin
thomas all hit it a really long way and
so is rory mcilroy
but bryson has gone about this in a very
unique and calculated way
that i think rich will have at least an
examination of how people go about
getting themselves
to the top of the sport so bryson if you
look back and we showed the video of him
winning the us amateur five years ago
his body's completely different he has
bulked up
he put on weight before the pandemic and
after he put on muscle
uh he's a physics major from smu and
rich he's gone about this in a very
scientific
way and his feeling is that i'm just
gonna hit as far as anybody ever
i'll just keep keeping it farther and
farther and farther and
take it out to the max length of driver
is his next goal take it out to a 48
inch length driver figure out how he can
come up with a swing that is repeatable
and just hit it as far down as possible
and hit a wedge onto the green
most folks thought it wouldn't work it
worked he was the only guy under par by
a wide margin at the u.s open so
this will definitely have folks thinking
about golf course design
approach to golf course does the ball go
too far should i just bulk up and hit it
as far as i can
all those things will be seriously
examined by the people in the sport in
various levels yeah i mean but
you still got to put it in the cup right
i mean you still got to hit it in the
right spot and get it and put in the cup
and get it done
rich there's a part b to hitting it as
far as anybody else
okay the the part b is with bryson
all of his clubs are one length all the
shafts are six iron length all the irons
at least
so his feeling is that he just turns
himself
into almost a human breathing machine
where it's the same swing
with the same length club but the loft
of the club
is obviously different as you go down
through the different irons and it feels
like it becomes more repeatable because
it's that one thing
when he puts he looks very uncomfortable
when he's putting
but you'll see he will like really
fidget with the
line on the ball he gets it on the right
line and he just feels like he hits it
back a certain
distance and forward a certain
difference with his back swing and his
first swing
on his putting he's you know he's the
guy who
when it became legal to keep the flag in
the hole
he doesn't do it on some downhill putts
because there's a different
weight of the pin itself at the masters
of the us open users and the pga tour so
like he's factored in everything of
everything of everything of everything
and he's turned it into a science
experiment which still requires physical
execution
right and he does it and you know some
some will look and i can't believe
a few years ago i was like oh this is a
little too much
i think a lot of us and i got changed in
mind talking to him at length over the
last year so
a lot of us are starting to open our
eyes and say maybe this is the best way
to go so good
good for him for changing the game and
giving people something to think about
and look at
before we move on from this i mean one
of the comments uh
from roger malpe over the weekend i i
have it right here in front of me
because it really
left out me when i heard it and he said
it during the broadcast
he said quote every part of me wants to
not like this
that you just reduce the game to power
and the fairway becomes less important
especially at the us open
that's just not the way it's been done
but this is impressive and he's
convincing me that he's not wrong in the
way that he's assessed how to play the
game
now so i ask you mike what are they
thinking do you think at augusta
after watching that what do you think's
going on right now
that that will that would be fascinating
as you said you stood at chippet and put
it put the ball in the hole and he did
out of the thick rough
there's almost no rough nothing even
close to the u.s open
at augusta so the question is will he be
able to
handle the greens usually if you handle
the greens at wingfoot west
it gives you a chance to be in that same
position at augusta i
i think so highly of roger he's one of
my
favorite people i've got a chance to
work with and be around i thought that
was really eye-opening roger came up
through a time when he played a certain
way
and covered 20 us opens for nbc and
it has seen the way that it's always
been gone about
but golf has often been resisted to
change
and to open your eyes and see that maybe
even if this isn't the way i think it
should be done
it is the way it can be done is
refreshing
look here i don't want to go too far
down this road
you mentioned tiger before rich we
thought tiger would bring minorities to
go
and and there are some more involved
what tiger really did was he brought
great athletes to golf
like it became cool to be dustin johnson
you know who's kind of like
you know nba you know nba type body
right
and six three or you know or a pitcher
or a first baseman or something like
that
and dustin johnson scoffer and so was
brooks kepka and so are all these guys
who are really really terrific athletes
tiger made golf really cool and i think
that's the longer impact the
physical conditioning the weight
training the athleticism
the nike golf is cool all that's i think
that's what tiger's
impact on the next generation of golfers
was
and now bryson deshamble is just taking
that to
hey let's go hit it far go ahead as far
as
who doesn't like to get up on the on the
tee and just hit as hard as you can
and see how far you can hit it the
difference is
yeah you still got to get it in the hole
you do you do that
i know i mean trust me if i if all i had
to do is go hit the weight
room and learn how to get that green
wedge and trivial pursuit like i i never
could
you know like
[Laughter]
you know could i slice some strokes off
my game i still have to execute you know
what i mean you still gotta swing and
you still gotta get in the hole
you know so what would you do so i was
thinking about that today
yes what would you do so could you if
you don't wanna make it just a who can
drive it farther contest here's what you
could do
leave the bunkers where they are so
bunkers are 300 310 you got to fly it
over or stay short of them
when it gets past 310 the fairway gets
more narrow that's fine
well you could put the worst rough on
the golf course
in the landing area at 330 340 and
beyond it's okay
you want to hit it 400 yards 390 380
whatever that number is going to be
great you got to hit in the fairway if
you don't hit in the fairway you're
going to be hitting out of
7 inches of rough that's impossible to
hit it out of that doesn't impact the
guy who's hitting at 295 300
310 yet if you're hitting it 360 370
380 off a tee which is obscene to think
about
on those holes you better hit it dead
solid perfect
otherwise you're going to be in the
worst rough possible and you're not
going to be able to get it on the green
within 30 or 40 feet that's the way you
can respond
but this is it look people want to see
him hit the next shot
and that's what brings people to tv you
want to see is aaron rodgers going to
make that unbelievable throw again
is tiger going to make the shot we've
never seen before will lebron do that
well now with the shambo you want to
watch him can he hit it 375 can he hit
it 380. yeah i want to see it
and that's good for the sport and just
in terms of entertainment
and level of interest i think mike
taurico here on the rich eisen show
the story line through the first two
weeks of the nfl season with
apologies to those playing in monday
night football uh would be what
well uh you know up until up until
yesterday was
i can't believe that this is happening
now right they've been able to figure
out the system and all that
and then as i was sitting we're on the
air with the opening you're watching
guys get hurt guys
there was like that hour where like okay
just nobody play for the next 15 minutes
we get past this hour where everybody's
getting hurt it was just
awful right you'd say no not another one
no not another 49er
that that was that was really
disappointing we've had weeks like that
week twos like that in the league in the
past but yes they just felt
uh even more raw for for whatever reason
uh
you know rich that cam cam and bill are
a fit
that is that brady it still doesn't look
normal in tampa and
pewter and all that stuff but he he he's
there and it's working out it's working
out pretty well
um i think the quarterbacks rich the the
lamar jackson patrick mahomes
all these guys kyler murray uh they're
the same thing i talked about with the
shambo like i want the next snap to come
because they're gonna do something
stupid
like what what mahomes did when i passed
the tyree kill that was the touchdown
was crazy
only doubled down with the two-point
conversion right after that which i
still don't know
how he got that open i know so the game
is really
fun right now isn't it oh a million
percent uh kyla murray is like uh
get your popcorn ready literally every
snap and yeah you know and
and and you never know and how he can
run and how he can throw
and again that that's but but your your
point again with cam
uh and bill being a match you know what
i mean like that to me
because i i honestly still think it's
the bill's division to lose
and josh allen's playing out of his mind
as well if you want to talk about
quarterbacks that you can't wait for the
next snap
you know but but the fact that cam were
wondering well what's the cam
that we're seeing because the fact that
cam was still sitting at home
um in the middle of the summer is still
such a head scratcher
and you could even say well what type of
cam are you getting with the foot and
the shoulder and all of that business
and the fact that 2015 cam has shown up
in new england
for for brady i mean for belichick and
mcdaniels to to gain plan with
that is a significant development that's
significant i
i i agree now there are a couple of
levels of the camp thing
you know where and i watch russell
wilson i think russell is the godfather
of this or aaron rodgers was when aaron
was running more
yes and russell has kind of kept that
going like the all-time master at
darren's
russell's baseball stuff also the
all-time master of these quarterback
slide and when he slides
he doesn't take hits i mean he does but
relative to
um you know running quarterbacks of the
past he's so wise about
the give you the right shoulder duck out
of bounds i'm gonna get two more yards
uh here's my little baseball pop-up
slide i'm not going to take a hit here
and the new guys do that kyler does that
lamar does
those guys now homes they get that they
do that
they stay healthy cam is a big running
back and he takes
all those hits and that just worries me
as a season goes on as he is not 21 but
31. so
that's the or i think that's his age
that's that i think maybe he's less than
that oh he is
i just worry about okay okay then i was
right i just worry about that with cam
so
two weeks i love it i hope he stays
healthy because it's fun ball to watch
it's good it's different they'll keep
expanding that package as they go
through the season
you know josh mcdaniels and bella
checking them what are you gonna get
you're gonna get everything you didn't
get last week
that's what you love about watching them
play can he keep doing that for an
entire season and stay healthy
running that power running game off the
off the left guard left tackle with the
right guard pulling to try to score
like he did on the last play last night
i hope he can keep going because
just like we were saying with the other
deal it's a blast to watch it really is
no doubt in the aforementioned rogers is
2-0 visiting new orleans for next week
for sunday night football
just phenomenal and then want to kind of
put on your radar screen
uh in form of our poll question is
philadelphia san francisco asked this
question of mike tarico
a fellow syracuse uh orange uh chris
brockman asked mike
go for it yeah mike uh who's in the most
trouble
after two weeks eagles falcons texans
49 i'm pulling you into the sports talk
radio morass mike
most trouble through two weeks knee-jerk
reaction what do you got
long time for long time first time
i'll go of the team she gave me i'll go
eagles and i'll tell you why okay
um the texans just played the two best
teams in the afc we think and
and they'll play next monday night right
with with the ravens ravens of the
chiefs
the 49ers injuries do concern me in
their division they concern me but i
still think that's a good football team
they will get some of those pieces back
as we go through the next stretch here
who's the other team that you threw in
there
the vikings we threw three oh and two
texans vikings eagles and then the
niners at one and one because of how
significantly they they suffered the
injury bug
yesterday no i'm not saying they're
going to repeat his nfc chance it's
going to be hard because i think they're
in the best division in the league
because i think every snap of those nfc
west games is like
great tv but the the viking
the vikings worry their offense has not
looked good they've given up
a lot of points and a lot of yards in
these first couple of games
how much does kirk cousins and how much
does the totality of that offense
miss what stephon diggs does it's like i
watched diggs go for you know his
eight for 150 something now deandre
hopkins
targeted 16 times week one eight catches
week two in arizona and go
okay i know houston's got a lot of good
receivers
they don't have the best or second best
receiver in the league anymore
i know minnesota's got good
complementary but they don't have
difference maker like stefan thinks has
been for them
so you can't just replace those guys who
require the extra attention so
minnesota is close there but the the
philly the philly thing doesn't doesn't
feel all that good but one advantage
philly has rich
is the division you know dallas doesn't
look like they're a juggernaut
obviously without saquon washington will
be growing with
their team so you have two teams in the
giants in washington who
or giants and football team i should say
who
don't feel like they're going to come
back and be a
juggernaut here during the season so as
long as philly can kind of hold serve
with dallas
you're still going to have a window
there in the nfc you're the best mike
you are the best great job as always
this weekend i appreciate the phone call
anything for you good to catch up man
say hi to your crew and
we'll be in touch with you pal right
back at you that's mike
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here